1619 project founder nicole hannah jones
has been denied
tenure at the university of north
carolina leftists are furious
squishes are worried and i for one could
not be happier because
academic freedom is for chumps it is a
hoax
as you can see very clearly from all of
our public debates
from transgenderism to the covid vaccine
i love that nicole hannah jones this
1619 project propagandist was denied
tenure at unc so the libs are furious
because the libs want this woman to push
her propaganda even more than
she already has let's not forget the
1619 project which is based on a lie
the entire thesis of the 1619 project is
that the american revolution was fought
to protect
the institution of slavery it's just not
true there is no evidence of this
whatsoever
even left-wing academic historians shot
this down the times persisted in error
for seven months but then even they
corrected it
and it was kind of a fake half
correction where they just added in
these words
some of they said some of the colonists
fought the revolution for this reason
even that is bogus it's just it the
american revolution
was not fought to protect the
institution of slavery that doesn't even
make sense
slavery would not be abolished
throughout the west for quite some time
afterward and there and there were
people
at the constitutional convention and at
the continental congress who were
fighting against
slavery regardless we are now being told
by the
would you call them libertarian right or
the squish right we're being told
that this is a grave threat to academic
freedom and i just
i just don't want to hear it anymore
this is what the libs do
they push some bogus idea and then for a
while the conservatives fight against it
and then we accept all of their premises
and then we start arguing their points
this is what happened with academic
freedom the modern conservative movement
the one that started after world war ii
began with william f buckley jr
publishing a book called god and man at
yale the subtitle of which was called
the the superstitions of academic
freedom he called it a hoax it's a joke
and it go it goes back much further than
that
academic freedom comes from the
university of leiden in 1575 it begins
after the protestant revolution
the university of leiden in the
netherlands decides that they're going
to have academic freedom
and yet even this first university with
total
you can say and think whatever you want
they refused to grant total academic
freedom then the protestant senate of
dort in 1618
restricted this even further because
they wanted to combat the armenian
heresy okay
keeping up so far then some german
universities tried to revive it for like
five minutes
napoleon shut that down then in 1636
harvard was founded in america was it
founded on academic freedom
no it was founded to quash the
antinomian heresy
these universities were founded with a
mission with a purpose they have to have
a mission
if you're going to teach anything you're
going to teach some things and you're
going to contradict other things
if you're going to teach the 2 plus 2
equals 4 you're not going to permit the
teaching the 2 plus 2 equals 5.
and this is not just true in mathematics
it's true throughout
the university in 1940
you have the american association of
university professors
this is the we're talking about the
height the peak of academic freedom in
america right
they issue their statement on academic
freedom and tenure so this is the actual
professors these are the guys who are
fighting in the trenches for academic
freedom and in their statement on
academic freedom
they say that teachers have the right to
quote freedom in the classroom in
discussing their subject
but they quote should be careful not to
introduce into their teaching
controversial matter
which has no relation to their subject
and later they told them to exercise
appropriate restraint
so even the most out there full-on
endorsement of academic freedom says
teachers can't mouth off about their
stupid politics and they need to use
restraint
and they're obviously accountable to the
trustees and to the parents
and to the university administrators
obviously
and yet the the right somehow adopts
these terms even the
bill buckley's intellectual heirs the
people who call themselves
buckleyites and things like that who now
are you know they're writing for places
like
i don't know the dispatch or something
you know these kind of
left-wing ostensibly right-wing outlets
they'll endorse this they'll say yeah we
support academic freedom it's just
a joke debates take place within limits
okay
you know what i'm gonna say i don't even
need to say it it should be out you
should have done it already
ring that bell subscribe like
the video make sure that you get the
notifications i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you